بعد رمي جمره العقبه في اول ايام العيد
الحجاج يستقبلون اول ايام التشريق برمي
الجمره الصغرى
[موسيقى]
انتهاء هدنه اليوم الاول في عيد الاضحى
وصل معارك متفرقه في انحاء مختلفه من
الخرطوم وولايات اخرى
انبائنا اعتقال القائد العسكري الروسيه
الاعلى السابق في اوكرانيا الجنرال
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى بعد تورته مع مجموعه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه بدا الحجاج في
مشعل مينا اول ايام تشريق حيث قاموا برمي
الجمرات الثلاث مبتدئين بالجمره فالمسطى
ثم الجمره الكبرى بعد ان قاموا يوم امس
برمي جمره العقبه ابوا تعمل الجهه المعنيه
على انسيابيه حركه الحجاج في جسر الجمرات
مع تطبيق خطه وتدابير وقائيه مكثفه لرمي
الحجاج للجمرات الثلاث بيسر وسهوله
لا اله الا
[موسيقى]
الله الله
اكبر ول
[موسيقى]
له
نيابه عن خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز استقبل ولي العهد
السعودي رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن
سلمان استقبل ضيوف الحج وقاده القطاعات
العسكريه المشتركه الامير محمد بن سلمان
نواه بجهود القطاعات العسكريه والجهات
الحكوميه المشاركه في الحج وقال ولي العهد
السعودي ان تضحيات الكبيره في الحج نهج
سار عليه ابناء السعوديه منذ تاسيسها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
ايها الاخوه القاده القطاعات العسكريه
والامنيه ومنسوبيها ايها الحضور الكرام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته يطيب لنا
نيابه عن سيدي خالد المحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه الله انه
يكرم ونهني المواطنين والمقيمين والحجاج
بيت الله الحرام بعيد الاضحى المبارك
ونسال الله العلي القدير ان يعيد على
بلادنا وعلى الامه الاسلاميه وهي تنعم
بالخير والسلام
انما تقدمونه من جهود مباركه وتقومون به
مع اجهزه الدوله الاخرى من اعمال متواصله
لخدمه حجاج بيت الله الحرام والسهر على
راحتهم والحفاظ على امنهم ومحل فخرنا
واعتزازنا وسنواصل بحول الله بدر الجهود
الامكانيات لتسيير اداء الحج كل عام الى
ما لا نهايه الى التضحيات الكبيره واعمال
الشرف في البطولات التي يقومون بها حفاظا
على امن بلادكم مقدساتها ونهج سار عليها
ابناء هذه البلاد منذ تاسيسها ولا يتوانى
عن حمايه امنها وصون استقرارها وحفظها
وحفظ مقدراتها نسال الله ان يحفظ هذا
الوطن ويديم عليه نعمه الخير والامان
والامن وكل عام وانتم بخير والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
قال مدير الامن العام للفريق محمد البسامي
في تصريحا للعربيه ان موسم الحج هذا العام
شاهد للمره الاولى عالميا توظيف
الخوارزميات بالشراكه مع هيئه البيانات
والذكاء الاصطناعي السعوديه
الى ان الروح مع ثوره الزمن اللي احنا فيه
الان اللي هو موضوع الذكاء اصطناعي توظيف
البيانات لذلك احنا دخلنا بشراكه مع سدايا
شراك الحقيقه يعني متميز بتوجيه سوى سيدي
وزير الداخليه الحج العليا وبمتابعه ايضا
لحظيه من معالي
الدكتور عبد الله شرف ايضا
نقول هذا هو المستقبل لذلك احنا سمينا حج
ذكي احنا بدينا بمجموعه كبيره من التقنيات
اول وظفنا
الخوارزميات لاول مره في مكان لا يوجد
مكان مماثل الا في مكه المكرمه وهو الحرم
المكي الشريف فلذلك الخوارزميات اللي بنيت
لهذا المكان من اي
من ايدي سعوديه وبقول سعوديين لهذا المكان
بالذات خاصه الان مجتهدف بملايين الرحلات
اليوميه من المعتمرين والزوار والحجاج
هذا واضافها البسامي في حديثه للعربيه ان
العقل البشري لا يمكن الاعتماد عليه كليا
في اداره الحشود بالحج وان الذكاء
الاصطناعي اصبح ضروره لتسهيل كافه المهمات
احنا اليوم كفريق لا يمكن نهائيا ان نعتمد
على العقل البشري او نعتمد على ادوات
البدائيه
نقول ان الاله حتساعدنا في موضوع دعم صاحب
القرار عندك حجم هائل من البيانات اليوم
نجمعها ونحطها في هالقالب هل الذكر
اصطناعي الان يطلعها لك بحيث انه الان
هالمؤشرات الموجوده تقول صاحب القرار ترى
عندك بؤر عندك تجمعات عندك احتمال يعني
حاله حمراء مثلا ولذلك تدخل قبل وقوع
الخطر هذا هو التوظيف الذكاء الاصطناعي
لكن بالمجانب الثاني اليوم احنا عندنا
منصه اخرى في
الحرام عندنا منصه اخرى في موضوع المنطقه
المركزيه
وضعنا اليوم هنا حنطوره مست قبلا باذن
الله بحيث انه الان
نرصد كل كثافه المضرب المركزيه في المشاعر
المقدسه في منها في مجتلفه في عرفات في
داخل حتى مع داخل مع
مداخل المكرمه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
[موسيقى]
انتهت هدنه اليوم الواحد في السودان رغم
ما شابه من اشتباكات متفرقه في اول ايام
عيد الاضحى كان القتال العنيف قد تجدد
يومي الثلاثاء والاربعاء فيما طالب قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان طلب الشباب
بالانضمام للجيش افاد سكان ان الضربات
الجويه والنيران المضاده للطائرات هزت
اجزاء من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم على
الرغم من اعلان كل من الفصيلين العسكريين
المتحاربين منذ منتصف ابريل عنه ابنه
بمناسبه عيد الاضحى المبارك
[موسيقى]
تولى مناصب رفيعه بين عامي
2008 عين العمليات في القوات المسلحه في
عام 2013 عين قائدا المنطقه العسكريه
الشرقيه في عام 2014
المشاركه الاولى في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
وارسال دبابات من منطقه روستوف
في عام 2017 عين قائدا للقوات الروسيه في
سوريا
في فبراير من عام 2023 قاده تطويق القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه بمدينتي غورسكي في
راس القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا ليتم
بعدها نقل المهمه الى رئيس الاركان
ما زال تفاصيل مخطط التمرد لقائد فاجنر
ايفغيني غير معروفه ويحيطها الغموض فيما
بعد المعلومات الاستخباراتيه تتكشف بين
الحين والاخر اخرها كشفته صحيفه وستري
جونيور نقلا عن مسؤولين استخباراتيين
مخطط تمرد زعيم فاجنر يتكشف قائد فادنير
خطط للاستيلاء على القياده العسكريه
لكنه تراجع بعد علم المخابرات الروسيه
بالمؤامره ليقرر بريكوجين الغاء مسيره
مسلحه باتجاه موسكو الهدف كان وزير الدفاع
رئيس الاركان العامه لروسيا لكن جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي علم بالخطه قبل يومين فقط
من موعد التنفيذ وافشل المخطط في 24 ساعه
[موسيقى]
ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا الدرب الروسيه التي
طالت مطعما شعبيا في بلده كراماتورسك بشرق
اوكرانيا الى 11 قتيلا من بينهم ثلاثه
اطفال و56 جريحا كما تم انتشار سبعه
في حين علق الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على
تصريحات الناطق باسم الكرملين دي لان
روسيا لا تستهدف بونا تحتيه مدنيه واصفا
الرئيس الروسي
وافقت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه على
الشراء بولندا لنظام المتكامل للدفاع
الجوي والدفاع الصاروخي بقيمه 15 مليار
دولار جاء في بيان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ان البيع المحتمل يلبي اهداف السياسه
الخارجيه وغاياتي ضمان الامن القومي
للولايات المتحده لانه يزيد من امن حليف
في الناتوته الى ذلك وافقت الولايات
المتحده على توريد قنابل جي بي يو 53 بي
الموجهه الى النرويج بصفقه تقدر بنحو 293
مليون دولار
مستمره وفيها بعد الف
اصل الازمه الاقتصاديه الخانقه تلقي
بضلالها على احتفالات السوريين بعيد
الاضحى المبارك
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت شرطه منطقه مكه انه
تم توقيفه شخصا يستقل سيار قرب القنصليه
الامريكيه بجده يحمل سلاح ناريا والجهات
الامنيه تحركت وتبادلت النار مع حامل
السلاح ماده لمقتله كما تعرض احد العاملين
في الحراسات الخاصه من الجنسيه النيباليه
الى اصابه ادت لوفاته من جهتها قالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه انه تم اغلاق القنصليه
بعد الحادثه ولم يصب اي مواطن امريكي
بالهجوم
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه ان
الوزيره جيمس كليفري سيدعو اليوم الى
توسيع مجلس الامن الدولي التابعه للامم
المتحده خلال خطابه الافتتاحي في مؤتمر
لندن 2003 امام مؤسسه شاتنه هاوس للابحاث
اضافه البيان وانا وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه سيطالب بتمثيل وعضويه دائما
لكل من الهند والبرازيل والمانيا واليابان
في مجلس الامن وسيقترح نظاما متعدد
الاطراف ومتجدد مجهز للتعامل مع التحديات
العالميه الاكثر الحاحا بما في ذلك
الانتهاك الروسي الصارخ لميثاق الامم
المتحده ووقف الهجره غير الشرعيه وتغيير
المناخ وثوره التكنولوجيا
الى سوريا حيث احتفل السوريون باول ايام
العيد في العاصمه دمشق بالتزامن مع ازمه
اقتصاديه حتى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في فرنسا اطلق محتاجون الالعاب الناريه
على الشرطه واحرقوا سيارات بضاحيه وذلك في
ثاني ليله من الشغب عقب مقتل الشاب يبلغ
من العمر 17 عاما برصاص الشرطه الفرنسيه
عند نقطه تفتيش المروريه فيما اعلنت
الحكومات الفرنسيه انه تم القول القبض على
31 شخصا بعد اعمال شغب احدى ضواحي باريس
كما اكدت اصابه 24 فردا من افراد قوات
الامن بسبب اعمال الشغب بدورها دعت
الداخليه الفرنسيه الى الهدوء وقالت ان
اعمال شاغبت سببت بحرق نحو 40 سياره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ورث الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اقتصادا
منهكا بفعل تبعاتي وباء كوفيد ثم التضخم
الحاد والتعثر سلاسل الامداد ما يجعله
يواجه صعوبه في حصد تاييد الامريكيين وفق
الوكاله الفرنسيه لان يراهنوا بايدا على
ادائه الاقتصادي لاعطائه دفعه لحملته
للبقاء في البيت الابيض في انتخابات العام
المقبل وسيعرض على الناخبين ما حققته
سياسته
خارطه طريق للفوز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه ترتكز على خطه اقتصاديه يراهن
الرئيس الامريكي انها ستجدد بقائه في
البيت الابيض مع توقعات ان تشهد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي ستجري العام
المقبل معركه شرسه في عدد من الولايات
المتارجحه في امريكا بايدن الذي يسعى بكل
قوه للفوز سيعرض على الناخبين ما حققته
سياسته التي اطلق عليها تسميه بايدونوميكس
التي سيطوي من خلالها صفحه بحسب البيت
الابيض لكن ماذا تعني هاتان التسميتان
بحسب لايل براين هارد مديره المجلس الوطني
الاقتصادي فان بايدن سيركز من خلال خطته
الاقتصاديه بايدنوميكس على القناعه بان
الاقتصاد ينمو حين تنمو الطبقه الوسطى
لهذا سيركز على دعمها
بخلاف خطه رياجانوميكس التي انتهجها
الرئيس الاسبقريجن وقامت على اساس توزيع
الثروات من الاعلى الى الاسفل على اعتبار
ان الازدهار سينعكس في نهايه المطاف على
الجميع لكن خطه واجهه انتقادات لمنحها
الافضليه للاثرياء والشركات الكبرى لذلك
بايدن يحاول التركيز على دعم الطبقه
الفقيره
وتقول ان النظريه تقطير الثروات بصوره
تنازليه الموروثه من عهد ريجن ادت الى
انهيار مدن صناعيه امريكيه في المقابل فان
سياسه بايدن الصناعيه الحاليه تستخدم بحسب
براينرد التمويل الحكومي كحافز لاحداث
ثوره انفاق في القطاع الخاص تستفيد منه
طبقه العاملين وتقلل نسب البطاله لكن هناك
تحديا يصطدم به بايدن مرتبط بان ان
انجازاته الاقتصاديه لا تنعكس كمكاسب
سياسيه لدى الناخبين حيث تظهر استطلاعات
الراي ان الاميركيين قل ما ينسبون فضل
تدني معدل البطاله الى الرئيس وسياساته
بدا رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مؤخرا في
استخدام جهاز تنفس لعلاج القطاعي النفس
اثناء النوم بحسب بلومبرد نقلا عن البيت
الابيض بعد ان شهدت علامات واشرطه على
جانبي او على جانبي وجهه خلال القائه
خطابا يوم الاربعاء في شيكاغو قال المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض اندروبيت انهم منذ عام
2008 كشف الرئيس قصته مع التوقف التنفس
اثناء النوم في تقارير طبيه في مقاله
مسؤول ان بايدن بدا في استخدام جهاز
التنفس في الاسابيع الاخيره لتحسين نوعيه
النوم
الارض تختنق بعد فقدانها العام الماضي
وحده مساحات من الغباء الاستوائيه تعادل
حجم دوله كامله او مساحه ملعب كره قدم كل
خمس ثوان حقائق مخيفه تؤثر على التنوع
البيولوجي وتخزين الكربون
غضب الطبيعه من حرائق وعواصف وامراض يرهق
كوكب الارض لكن اطماع البشر ساهمت باحداث
نزيف بيئيا قد يصعب ايقافه فالارض فقدت
خلال العام الماضي مساحه من الغابات
الاستوائيه البكر تعادل مساحه سويسرا او
هولندا اي نحو اربعين الف كيلو مترا مربع
الرقم يصبح مرعبا اكثر حين معرفه ان هذا
الدمار يوازي مساحه 11 ملعب كره قدم من
الاشجار الاستوائيه المقطوعه او المحروقه
كل دقيقه دمار كبير لحق بانظمه بيئيه
بدائيه وشكل زياده قدرها عشره في المئه
مقارنه بعام 2021 وقد سجلت منصه جلوبال
فورست ووتش المتخصصه بمراقبه ازاله
الغابات عبر الاقمار الصناعيه تدمير اكثر
من اربعه ملايين ومائه الف هكتار من
الغابات الاوليه الاستوائيه وهي مساح
الطبيعيه بالغه الاهميه للتنوع البيولوجي
على كوكب الارض ولتخزين الكربون فالغابات
المدمره اطلقت نحو مليارين وسبعمائه مليون
طن من ثاني اكسيد الكربون اي ما يعادل
الانبعاثات السنويه للهند علما بان اكثر
البلدان تضررا في هذا المجال هي البرازيل
حيث تمثل المنطقه المدمره فيها ثلاثه
واربعين في المئه من الخسائر العالميه
وتمتص غابات الامازون المطيره حوالي 90
مليار طن من ثاني اكسيد الكربون اي ضعف
الانبعاثات العالميه السنويه اما السبب
الرئيسي بفقدان الغطاء الشجري فيكمن
باستخدامها من اجل الزراعه وتربيه المواشي
وانتاج الفحم الحيوي فالازاله العمد
ارتفعت بنسبه 3.6
عام 2022
احتفالا باليوم الدولي لمكافحه المخدرات
اطلقت كمبوديا عمليه وطنيه لحرق واتلاف
كميات معتبره من المخدرات بانواعها وبحضور
السلطات المدنيه والامنيه
في نهايه نشره تذكيرهم بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
الله بعد رمي جمره العقبه في اول ايام
العيد الحجاج يستقبلون اول ايام التشريق
برمي الجمره الصغرى
انتهاء هدنه اليوم الاول في عيد الاضحى
وسط معارك متفرقه في انحاء مختلفه من
الخرطومه ولايات اخرى
انباء على اعتقال القائد العسكريه الروسيه
الاعلى السابق في اوكرانيا الجنرال
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى بعد تورطه مع مجموعه
فان
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات